[Music]
here we go again
the emotional rollercoaster that we call
ps+ this month most definitely is a high
June 2019 these games are mind-blowing
keep in mind you can't download them
until the first Tuesday of the month so
that's June the fourth there's also a
few PS plus extras for dauntless and
apex legends players so if you're ready
let's do this game number one the
headlining game for June is none other
than Borderlands the handsome collection
this includes both Borderlands 2 and
Borderlands the pre-sequel if you
haven't ever tried Borderlands 2 I
demand that you do so a tight
first-person shooter which
single-handedly defines the early days
of looter shooters there are so many
weapons in this game that it's literally
impossible to see them all the storyline
in Borderlands 2 is also stellar with
one of the greatest villains to ever
grace a video game
handsome jack himself the other portion
of the game is Borderlands the
pre-sequel which happens many moons
before the events of Borderlands 2 and
shows us how handsome Jack began that
downfall he's so evil he even has a body
double bottle and two has many 9 out of
10 scores and did it be a travesty to
miss this by playing through both games
you'll have a great understanding ready
for Borderlands 3 this September oh by
the way I have exclusive gameplay of
Borderlands 3 if you'd like to see that
I'll link it now each of these games
includes all the DLC all improvements
and only last month the handsome jack
collection was updated to support 4k
visuals or if you prefer 60 frames a
second at 1080 P even if you hate the
visuals please give this a go it's
definitely worth your time and if you
enjoy it please check back for tons of
Borderlands 3 coverage over the summer
game number 2 for June 2019 is another
brilliant title Sonic mania Sonic may be
a retro classic but this brand new
adventure brings the blue bombshell into
modern day by taking the best elements
of all the previous Sonic games in
history it's one big Easter Egg just
trying to find a new audience you may
not think 2d platformers are your kind
of thing but once again I ask you to try
it anyway it will keep all DS happy like
me but it's challenging enough to keep
the most competitive gamer enthralled
until the end credits with Sonic Tails
knuckles and of course
- Robotnik hang on you call him dr.
Robotnik on dr. Eggman this should make
up for the movie's delay and if you're
wondering sonic mania also includes
competitive and cooperative game modes
perfect to play with your family I'm not
sure about you but I'm extremely happy
already with these offerings but wait
there's more
PS Plus subscribers can also receive
in-game items from many games this month
there is a second apex legend pack with
skins for characters and weapons and
those who downloaded dauntless this week
can grab PlayStation weapons perfect for
transmogrification so there we have it
what do you think the June's PS Plus
offerings I already have both the games
but dammit I'm happy for other people to
play these let me know your thoughts in
the comments below let's see if this is
the first time that everyone's happy it
hasn't got a chance has it I'm Adam from
Playstation grenades been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]